growing up
um with the wrong information growing up
with what um
role models as family members um
in the ghetto you know on the hood we
had this certain lingo
that we spoke on and um everything that
i was taught
from an early age was was all bad
but in a sense but in a sense it was
good because
our conversations were about getting
over on the system
but i'm like what system was that and
the system was being poor black and in
the ghetto that was
our prison kind of setting that was our
training ground
and um i remember being
14 15 and
you know the the older guys telling me
my older uh role models
yeah man get in as much trouble as you
can before you turn 18 because once you
turn 18 you're going to hit the county
and once you get there minnesota is a
whole nother level
now they painted this picture of prison
being like camp snoopy you know they had
the weights they had the tv
they had cigarettes they had coffee so
to me it was like going on an adventure
say going to the amusement park like a
magic mountain or knoxville reform
that's the way i depict the prison back
then even though i've never been there
because it was the picture that was
painted to me made it so alluring
it's like oh man i can't wait to
experience that and um
not knowing that it'll be one of those
kind of
um home away from homes that just you
know completely just engulfed me man and
it kind of had me messed up
in more ways than one
first time i went to prison um i had a
lot of stuff going on
you know in my life at the time and i
needed a break
so um i think i was sentenced to 16
months
16 would have for a strong arm robbery
and i did 10 10 months in a couple weeks
but they had sent me the fire account
and i was fighting fires
and um what an adventure that was me and
being in the cabin
being in the mountains you know away
from society and nobody
fits no guard towers or not like that um
eating like a king and being on the
front line fighting fires
that was a hell of an adventure and that
was the first impression i got
from prison that was it you know
i came in uh uh um looking like alfalfa
and and i came home looking like the
rock in 10 months man
that transformation just took place and
i was like oh man it's everything
they said it was plus more prison
you know but i didn't even know at the
time when i was i was i was in prison in
my own mind
body and spirit probably going there and
my the cool thing about it is i was
looking at that
looking at that part as a release you
know and um
everything things were hard on the
streets and i couldn't maintain and
couldn't handle
i knew where to go to find that release
to to to
to get that pressure off of me you know
dealing with the um
things that were going on in the 80s you
know the 80s were the roughest
part of my life you know i i can't stand
the 80s
what i went through what i experienced
and being exposed to in the 80s you know
with everything that was going on in the
neighborhood back then
and um the 80s man i couldn't wait to
escape man
and um i found the way out you know
i didn't know the wrong way but yet and
still i found the way out from dealing
with that [ __ ] family situation
from dealing with the crack epidemic and
for dealing with that gang stuff that
was going on
it was all these different things going
on in my life at the time and i just
didn't know how to deal with it
for the life of me i just i just
couldn't i couldn't fathom
growing up in a predicament that i was
in
and um just saw myself drowning in
quicksand
you know at the same time and then
looking around and couldn't see no help
there was no help for me back then and i
knew it
[ __ ] i know i was in deep trouble
and um that [ __ ] kind of hurt me
and um so my second trip to prison um
i did another strong ground robbery and
they gave me four years once again
i went to fire account so i'll go
through the um
pft and all that kind of stuff and i
excelled at the exercise of the jumping
jacks the running the mall and the
pull-ups and the dips and all that
and mind you they have weights and um
once again um the second time i turned
up in prison you know i was looking like
alfalfa
you know scrawny skinny 155 soaking wet
and um i think i did 27 months on that
joke and i came out like 220
[ __ ] huge man looking like an action
hero for real you know
because i didn't even look real to
myself and then when i see encounter
people on the streets like my family
they said my god eric you know man
what happened [ __ ] i don't know you
guessed as good as mine
i guess it was that good eating fighting
the fires being in the best shape of my
life
in my 20s as i was going through that
experience with the prison
now mind you my first impression was
fire camp eating good making good money
and not being around no guards and all
that kind of stuff no walls and a barbed
wire
but as i kept going back and forth it
started getting worser
and worser and worser and um
i think my third time they didn't send
me the fire camp because my point said
when
my point said rose because of the uh two
prior trips are going to prison
now i have five prior commitments
and i have about 15
um what's called 15 uh um
parole violations you know one year
seven months
this that and um but on my third time
man i didn't go to fire camp
they said i don't qualify for it because
my case was a serious violent
so back in this time they had the three
strikes going on they had all these laws
coming up and
things were slowly changing in the
system man and um
i didn't i didn't really notice it until
it was too late but by the time i
came to the realization about the
changes that was going on in prison
man i was already lost in the sauce you
know and um what i mean by that is
they start taking things away they start
making it where
it wasn't fun no more wanting to go to
prison you know i mean i got to the
level three yard
it was way different than fire camp you
had the selves in a sale living with a
with a selling they have the bar bar the
gun towers and no warning shots and all
that [ __ ]
so that was like a uh uh culture shock
to me
because i was used to to camp snoopy
disneyland
and my reality was far from that it
wasn't a more dizzy lamb it wasn't no
more uh camp snoopy
you know it was where you really had to
build your p's and q's man there wasn't
no guarantee you make it home
and i was like god damn you got to be
kidding me
ain't no guarantee no guarantee not here
you know and for the first time i got to
see the difference
in how the longer people stay in prison
say the lifers they come home you know
they got more stuff going on
now for me i think when i went there
i'll probably have maybe three years
they sentenced me to three years for
a gun that didn't belong to me and um i
think i was home for two days only
and i went back two days on the streets
went right back and that's when they
sent me to that level three for the
first time
and um i never knew anything about ptsd
but i understand being in prison it's
that kind of thing that goes on in there
now while you're in there you got to
stay on top of your game
you got to use your a game you got to
stay with your race
you they got the prison politics
[ __ ] going up in here so you got to
play it out
and most importantly you got to stay out
of trouble you know you got to learn how
to do your program
but stay out of the way of others and
that's not easy
because there's always something that's
allowed to happen in prison
beyond your control like the riots
lockdowns modified programs and so it
was dangerous
now i remember saying my fourth fifth
trip going back and forth
it didn't dawn on me that i experienced
something
worse than being on the streets with my
belt with the crack
with the environment and everything that
came with that now that was a heavy
burden to carry on the streets because
being addicted
ain't no joke and um so i remember
coming from prison
coming home i don't give a damn how long
i was gone and then ending up in the
same spot where i left out at [ __ ]
with that crack
i mean how the [ __ ] i get here because
in that other place it was
worser but in a different way
you know i had to it's like going
to the middle the military boot camp i
had to gear up and be prepared mind body
spirit
for this for this prison war kind of
setting not the jungle war but the
prison the concrete war
the concrete jungle you know that's what
prison was man
you know you had these races up in there
and you know everybody stays separate
and all that [ __ ] and
you know they had everything set up man
and you know we had our own separate
tables and
you know it's like going back into my
[ __ ] 60s man where we had to color
drink a fountain in the white
that's what it felt like in prison
mexicans said they [ __ ] table
we had our two or three the whites have
theirs and
i'm like man you know we can interact
with each other but
you know there was there was lines that
you couldn't cross in there
you know or there was some consequences
so you know
the more i was going the more i got wise
to the enter
the intertwinings of of the prison set
and most importantly
the most important factor man that i
missed was not
seeing it as a plantation man as the
the the the the the the
i started in 87 you know going to prison
and everything but i never looked at it
as
going to a slave plantation until later
on man because the more
i kept going back and forth the more i
started reading books making inquiries
and really taking a look around
they have 34 prisons in california alone
in the majority of them
set up of men of color and that's the
god's honest truth and if i didn't go so
many [ __ ] times i wouldn't know
that
but my experience tells me that because
i hadn't been to about 15 different
prisons
in california alone during my
19 trips you know
it was fun at the beginning but in the
end it wasn't fun no more
wasn't nothing funny about going to
prison not when reality set in
[ __ ] but i was already it was too late
for me i was already entangled in that
[ __ ]
and for the life of me i couldn't find
my way out of it
and um so what happened was the more
i was going back and forth and seen
that it wasn't all cracked up but it was
supposed to be
it still didn't dawn on me man because i
was always looking at prison
as my home away from home which in turn
became my home from home
because i did more time in prison that i
did on the streets during my 20s and my
30s
and i think the last time i went in i
went in at 43
and i came out at 50. i'm 53
right now but my last trip i did about
six and a half close to seven years man
and
um that was my last belt with visiting
you know my home away from home here
and um well i just like to share
something about the
the the prison set man and how it was
set up
and um so i'm i'm looking at it as a way
to escape my reality on the streets but
it was so it was
it was at the point where i think in
they saw where we were benefiting
from the coffee from the cigarettes from
the weights and the guards were getting
scared of us because we were going
scrawny and come out like the
the incredible hulk you know and i paid
witness to that man i think on my trip
when i did four with half man i came out
so huge i look like arnold in his prime
[ __ ] cut man ripped on swole
blew my mind and that's what i should
look forward to
by going to prison was those kind of
experiences led aside to race riots and
all that other [ __ ]
my my whole thing was if i end up in
prison i know what i'm gonna do
i'm abide by the rules and the
guidelines i'm gonna be the model
[ __ ] inmate
and i'm gonna get on swole and try this
[ __ ] on the streets again
not knowing that i was bringing some of
the [ __ ] from the prison set
out on the streets what compacted it
where i i couldn't succeed on the
streets because i took the [ __ ] from the
streets that i endured
took it to prison thinking i'm escaping
and just adding some more stuff to the
equation
that had nothing to do with the streets
but the prison kind of bylaws and
guidelines and i brought that [ __ ] to
and it just didn't work it didn't work
so what i learned on the streets
that [ __ ] don't work in prison and what
i learned to prison it doesn't work on
the streets
it's two different settings man it's two
different i didn't know it at the time
so what happened was i got caught up in
the
into just knowing that once i got to
prison
i know it wasn't going to be all good by
far but i knew it was going to be all
bad either
so in 1987 excuse me 1990
i started in 87 so 10 years into it
1997 they took the weights off the yard
they went from taking all the heavy
stuff and leaving us so so much like
they say they take the 150 dumbbells
down to the 100
to the 95s and the 80s they leave us the
75s on down
they take all the extra quarters in a
world a 50 and a 25 75 only for the
bench
so they took the majority of weights and
left us very little to work with
because they said we were just coming
home too big and the guards were
um the guardsmen were they weren't in
shape they weren't at the top of the
game you know being a prison guard
you just go there to do your thing and
go home so they wasn't tripping on
trying to be in shape a few
were health conscious but the majority
of the prison guards there
they just they're there to do their job
man they're going home like they pay
i'm not mad at them
so i they took the weights they took the
majority of the heavy the extra stuff
and right behind that they took all the
waste off the yard
right up under our noses they just came
one day with some trucks
and he had these inmates come man and
they just took
everything off the yard man it took them
maybe
two days and they had a some modified
program
you know we just went and eat and went
back to our dorms because
they didn't want to surround that while
it was taking place man until they were
done
and it took two days for them to take
everything off the yard i didn't see it
at the time as a deterrent to keep
people from wanting to come back and
forth i couldn't see it back then
but they was trying to come up with
different methods so your ass wouldn't
want to come to prison no more they
didn't want to make it easy you want to
make it look like cam snoopy which it
was back then
they said well you know the guys don't
mind coming in enough they don't mind
coming back and forth because of the
setup the layout
and um so they started with the weights
now what's most important in prison is
weights
coffee and tobacco guess what was next
on the list
i think i um i think shortly after that
they took the um
the tobacco off the yard and um
i say 85 percent of men in prison smoke
cigarettes drink coffee
and work out 85 out of 100 that's a lot
so the prison is making a killing on
tobacco
and uh coffee of course and uh
like i said when they had the weights
and everything to work out kind of thing
going on because everybody
in prison was health and fitness even if
your ass didn't want to you had to get
your ass in line
just in case some [ __ ] jumped off you'd
be you know you'd be a little bit in a
better position to take care of yourself
so all races
it was mandatory that you work out i
love working out so it wasn't mandatory
for me [ __ ] when i went to prison
now you couldn't keep me up the weights
you know that was my thing you know
and um but for for some people it wasn't
their thing but they had no choice
because like i said
what applies in there doesn't apply out
here and vice versa
after they took the the tobacco
you know people was in the uproar man
because like i said that's one of the
number one money
money factors in prison men is tobacco
and uh
once they took that man it still didn't
dawn on me
that they were trying to make it hard
instead of easy man
you know they were trying to deter me
but i couldn't see it back then man
because like i said i was lost in the
politics of the [ __ ] and i had my own
troubles in there and i had my own
troubles on the streets
so it was like damn my dread when it's
time for me to parole and go home i
dreaded
going home man and then when i did my
[ __ ] on the streets and got caught
it's like god and to somebody graduated
going to prison
you know because of the [ __ ] that
came with it you know and plus
they take the weights off the york they
took the tobacco and i loved easter
island
back in prison they had a bugler rolling
tobacco and i was a beautiful
connoisseur man i really held up some
uh uh cigarettes you know i mastered it
you know i could roll one behind my back
man with one hand
you know and um [ __ ] i brought took my
show on the road man i took it to the
streets man and i was on the streets
going to the tobacco shop back in the in
the early 90s man behind the can of you
look like 20 bucks man
and coming over 200 papers and i'm
rolling my ass off man and walking down
the street
i remember some uh lep officers lapd
officers driving by
looking because it looked like marijuana
sticks but they're just roaming tobacco
but i wrote them like like i said like
uh they look like uh
joints you know and um i was on bugler
man
even after they weren't popular more on
the streets even you know because people
started going to like regular cigarettes
so i went from the buglers to the
[ __ ] camel non-filters
you know because that was another thing
this this mantra about being in prison
you know everybody
you you knew who was in prison from what
they smoked on the streets so if you see
somebody with a pouch of bugler
you know that [ __ ] from prison
if you've seen somebody with a pack of
camelot filters you know
he was from prison too but it seemed
like in the higher levels they was doing
a
camel non-filters in a fire camp stuff
like that they were doing the rolling
tobacco
and um so
i think my my seventh day trip
it started getting worse and worse in
there man they started coming up with
all these guidelines all these rules and
all that [ __ ] man they made it hard
on you
and i still couldn't see it you know i
still couldn't see that they was really
trying to get a get a hold on
people not wanting to come back and
forth to prison man and if
and in the beginning in the beginning
for me man it was
you know it was like playing the captain
mouse game
you know
what what i can get away with while i'm
in there you know how can i
slick you know that the counselors and
the gourds and all that kind of [ __ ] by
being a smile to win me
but really putting forth an effort man
but just not having nothing to work with
man because they didn't give you nothing
viable
in prison you know it just i just knew
what i had coming when i got there i
knew what time count was
i knew what jobs they kind of gave out
you know you don't import a kitchen
worker
um [ __ ] like that education and uh
special services you know that was it
that's all they it was limited to what
you could do
in prison as far as workers already knew
going in what i was going to do
get my man put me in the kitchen yeah
put my ass right there in the back
doing the pots and pans so i can be out
the way and i can steal everything i got
my hands don't mean to sell it back to
the fellas when i get there
the bell peppers the onions the mustard
whatever man
you know i was in there surviving man
trying to survive man
because it's hard in prison when you're
in there by yourself and you don't have
no support it's hard as hell
and a lot of people couldn't couldn't
take it man and they sunk
and um so they got up into
the black market kind of thing in prison
cell phones
tobacco drugs i didn't play that [ __ ]
i'm like man [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i want to go home when it's my turn to
go home because everybody get a turn to
go home
i just didn't know all those trips
leading up to my 19th that i didn't have
a plan and i wasn't prepared for home
so even i was a model inmate even though
i did all the self-help classes even
though i came in one way it came out a
different way
i was still working with the same
information i was still working with the
same thing emotionally i was still
working with the same kid
mentally you know i was just getting
older in age
you know as the trips came on as you
know from from my first trip to like the
15th trip
i was 18 then i felt myself at 35 by my
18th trip
and from 18 to 35 i was still working
with the same old feelings man didn't
nothing changed from 18 to 35 i don't
give a [ __ ] if i'm 1000 times in prison
did nothing change man
i was still working with that same
mindset
prison didn't have no psychiatry didn't
have no counseling he didn't have all
that
the 101s in there man you was on your
[ __ ] own up in there
and either your ass was going to swim
with you it was going to sink and by me
it seemed you was going to get your
ass rolled up to the sy yards and all
that kind of stuff man and
all my 19 trips i went to general
population
um i never put myself in a position
where i had to get rolled up and
and moved off the yard man because i
didn't play that [ __ ] i know what i have
to do
and i did it well up in prison i just
wish i would have had just as much
success
as i had in prison by walking that fine
line
like on the streets i couldn't walk that
fine line on the street smell like i did
near
but i had the guards hovering over me i
had the inmates hovering
to make sure that i didn't uh falter and
have a misstep
because in in there you have a misstep
that's your ass
i'm not playing you talk about some [ __ ]
going on up in there man
my brother's not paying attention and
and following the rules and guidelines
in there man
the consequences are deep and they're
heavy
and um
so it took me i think my 19th trip man
to prison
where i finally got it so what happened
was nothing changed from
the the the routine that i had
established for my first time
being a fire cam i still worked out
every [ __ ] day i still did all
the self-help classes i still did the
church and all that kind of stuff and i
still stayed
up the way man i stayed in my lane you
know
and that didn't change because it worked
now i didn't have no success on the
street with it but it worked in there
so [ __ ] if it ain't broke don't fix it
and um what happened was man
this time when i paroled
things started to click for me i kind of
see
where the way the prison is set up is
set up for you
not to succeed but to feel because
prison is
what you put into it is what you get up
out of it if you don't put nothing to it
then your ass ain't got nothing coming
so
having having been sentenced to nine
years
what 80 percent it wasn't just no in and
out back and forth like i've been you
know going up to the
to the 18 times seven months nine months
three months
four months five months two years three
years 60 months four years
it wasn't that in and out back and forth
kind of [ __ ] like now you see me now you
don't
when they gave me that nine years with
80 i really had to sit my ass down
and really take a look at what was going
on around me all the time that i didn't
see the first 18 times
i saw a lot of men come in there didn't
put a [ __ ] thing into it
and when it was time for them to get
their turn to take their ass home
scared to death because they didn't have
no plan it wasn't prepared now
i remember getting up in the morning
because they should release us
in prison like that's after breakfast
sometimes so you have to be in oronora
like by nine in the morning
so they give you a little your little
parole clothes all that [ __ ] and
take it to the train the bus station
give you a little two hundred dollars
and that's it
see ya good luck god speed
and i remember being in the in the tv
room or the game room or whatever the
[ __ ] i happened to be at that time
and i see these men you know being
called to have
to go home and i should watch them and
someone be so
scared and so i can see the despair
written over their face
because they really didn't do a
[ __ ] thing while i was there
man they just went through the motions
i've been through the motions a lot of
times in the beginning i think the first
15 [ __ ] trips to me i went
through the motions
then i wonder why i didn't i didn't
stand a chance out here on the streets
[ __ ] if you wanted you got to get it and
i didn't see that at the time i know how
to work i know how to get it when it
came to weight training i love it
i know how to get that i know everything
in and out about training man about
bodybuilding you know [ __ ] that's me
love it
but the last trip i was just watching
and the more i paid attention the more
things started to click for me and it
came together for me
and i saw how prison is not designed to
help your ass
it's not built to to to help you succeed
when you get your [ __ ] ass back
on the streets
prison is there for you to pay your debt
to society for whatever [ __ ] you did
prior
on the streets they got you in the
judicial court system they got you
sentenced to a place like that
it's not there to do the pep talks to
help you
man it's you got to pay your debt
whatever crime it is
you know so it's not set up
it's not designed as a good place to
want to go
you know it's it's a place that even
more so now before before i parole
this last time when they took they took
so much stuff and they changed the rules
so much
i fell because it started like i said i
started really watching and paying
attention because i was there for a long
time
it just wasn't no end and no hop
skipping the jump i really sat
they set my ass down long enough for me
to really see what was going on around
me and why it was so hard for me to stay
out of there and while it was so hard
for me to stay successful on the streets
because i tried to combine the two
together and they just don't mix it's
like oil and water
and i always try to try to take some of
the good stuff from prison
and apply it on the streets but it never
worked and i tried to take some of the
good morals and values i was learning to
take that [ __ ] man they don't give a
[ __ ] about that
how you was raised and how good you are
so i tried to be the model inmate
in prison where they don't give a [ __ ]
about no model inmate
and i tried to i tried to be the model
citizen
on the streets where most characters
most cats
man they don't give a [ __ ] about no
model uh uh uh productive citizen
you know [ __ ] crackholes in the
hood
they can care less about that you better
not be talking about what you learn and
what you gain
probably get your throat cut cause ain't
nobody on that page ain't nobody trying
to hear that good
that good [ __ ] not from where i come
from
you better be about to hustle about the
paper about the money
because you feel if it don't make
dollars it don't make sense
and um yeah i was convinced that at one
time but not no more man
you know so what i did man my last trip
man i did what made my [ __ ] ass
happy
and that was just to pay attention and
watch all the comings and goings
and kept my mouth shut and they're more
observing then i realized why it never
worked i realized
i realized now why things never panned
out when things never worked out
because i was applying the wrong the
wrong methods to the streets and vice
versa
so i got hooked up with the right people
i took advantage of the teachers the
instructors that was here
i got all the information i could and it
was it was it was back and forth
and when i paroled your march april may
i parole may 17 2017
man i ain't look back i ain't mr b
because for the first time in my life
man of out of all those [ __ ]
trips to prison
i had a plan and i was prepared
but you know what it might have took
you know those 18 times prior just to
get me to that place
where i said enough is enough and i
better do something about my dire
situation
because in the beginning it wasn't a
dire situation until i got
until i started at 18 and then i went in
at 43. so when i when i was at 43 with
that nine years i'm like god
damn man it ain't no game it ain't no
joke up in here
man this [ __ ] ain't no game ain't no
guarantee i'm going home i got the ptsd
the longer your ass dip in there you're
to come on with some kind of problems
ask the lifer and do 26 or 30 years and
get his ass home
it's going to take him a long time to
get that [ __ ] about a system
whatever it is and me doing six and a
half years
man it's some of the stuff it's still
seeping through my pores man still
running through me
you know i didn't know back and forth in
and out that it just accumulated
accumulated accumulated accumulated and
i've been holding on to the stuff for as
long as i could remember
now i'm finally able to release it
but it's not easy it'll never be easy
because i'll notice all the [ __ ] i've
been through in prison
would not know what you know i've been
in some rides man i've been with the
with the fights and all that and being
close to the knives and all that
[ __ ] and
the gun shots i've been through all of
that but for the life of me when i came
home i couldn't talk
i didn't have nobody to talk to talk to
about that stuff i experienced in prison
i don't give a [ __ ] if i went a thousand
times
my 19 trips to prison every time i came
home i didn't talk about that nobody
want to hear about that
so i kept that [ __ ] bottled up inside of
me all my experiences in prison
so i didn't have no release so i'm
walking around with all that [ __ ] on
my shoulders
then i come on the streets and i got to
deal with the family situation the
family dynamics
not having a personal relationships with
nobody then with the crack cocaine
[ __ ] episode and
and all that so it was just i was just
like a walking time bomb
and it took me a long time man to see it
for what it was
you know that's why it is so imperative
for me to talk about this stuff man
because i've been holding i've been
holding on to it for so long it'll kill
me
and if i don't talk about i've had my
ass back in prison it's inevitable
because that's all i know in and all
back and forth i don't know nothing else
[ __ ] if i did i'll practice something
different
it's like the home training man what i
was told is just what i was talking give
a [ __ ] about the wrong information
it's all they have to offer me and i can
live with that
even with the mistakes man i'm cool with
that because i know sooner or later
there had to be a change come about
but i know the change was gonna have to
come from within me it started with my
ass and i was gonna end with me i don't
give a [ __ ] who guided me who misled me
along the way that's irrelevant
because i am responsible for me
i'm responsible for me i got to take
care of me i got to look out for me do
the best i can for me because that's all
i got is me
hell not going to do a perfect job i
wish i did but nothing beats a failure
but a tribe
and um i had i hit those milestones you
know
50 50 years old finally got my driver's
license for the first time
you know i've been home lived over three
years that's a hell of a milestone
you know i think the most i've ever
stayed home was maybe a little over two
years
doing my 19 trips almost two years i was
able to almost able to stay home
before i had went right back and the
last time like i said before was two
days man
so this is a milestone for me you know
i'm happy at where i'm at in my life
it's never easy
dealing with reality when i've been
shucking and driving bobbing and weaving
and escaping it for so long
finally getting to the place or the
point in my life i'm really able to deal
with it for what it is see it for what
it is
life my experience and everything that
come about it that makes me who i am
and um it wasn't easy
overcoming prison because my first
impression
was was that was the one that got me
that was the one that hooked me which
was the power cam so wasting all that
stuff the tv the coffee and the
cigarettes and all that [ __ ]
it was alluring man and um it was like a
dream come true
you know and um towards the end the
picture was you know it
it changed and when it changed in a
prison sentence
i just wasn't capable of changing with
it at the time so i had to go back and
forth i had to do some more [ __ ]
i had to do some more before my eyes
started to finally open
to see the reality of prison how it
wasn't that normal it hasn't been like
that in a long time
but that was what i was going on that's
what that was that's what motivated me
knowing what it used to be like
but it had changed before my very eyes
and it took me a long time to see that
change take place
so anything that i do anything that i
say
you know hopefully it doesn't have to
take as long
you know but it seemed like my
experiences with life with drugs with
relationships with prison
with rehabs it it man it didn't take the
first
trip or or the umptee [ __ ] trip
man even in my rehabs and i think i've
been to 30 programs
prior to you know just leading up to
here man
you know 30 of them [ __ ] man
and i put my best fourth i put my best
foot
i put my best foot forward and in all
those 30 vain attempts at trying to get
my life together from the crack man
now that's a hell of a story right there
if you want to speak on that and it'll
be a pleasure to talk about the rehabs
man cause i wasn't bullshitting
when i went to get that help i really
wanted that help i really wanted that
change i really wanted to be that man
god created me to be
just like when i went to prison i didn't
want to go i didn't want to leave the
same way i came in
but i didn't know at the time man that
what i put into it is what i got up out
of it so i was just going through the
motions in the beginning because that's
what everybody was doing in prison just
going through the motions just bonding
until they turned and came home to go
home again
and i was i was just in line waiting for
my [ __ ] turn to go home
but really didn't change really and put
forth an effort then i wonder why i went
right back
over and over and over i wonder why i
couldn't get about that
entanglement i wonder why i said man
when they got too hard out here man i
don't give a [ __ ] man send my ass back
to prison what took you so long
because i meant that because
what was that normal became normal for
me
it became a part of my lifestyle part of
my character trait
prison you know i didn't wear there's no
badger honor or no [ __ ] like that
but it was just an intricate part of me
and um it took me a long time to to see
it for what it was
in a break those shackles you know and
um
so i'm learning how to break those
shackles on the street man with my mind
man being a person on my mind out here
on the streets man
you know i see it for what it is out
here it's a beautiful day
i love being free i love being home i
love putting my best foot forward
you know put one foot in front of the
other come with me yeah i make my
mistake [ __ ] i wish i was perfect
but i'm not perfect but i do the
[ __ ] best i can with what i'm
working with
and i can live with that i don't know
about nobody else
i'm not no quitter i'm a fighter and i
want to be more than just a survivor
i want a life worth living man and so
far so good
i'm realizing that that dream one of
those unspoken prayers let me have my
own place
now i'm working on getting the
transportation but there's some things i
have to do in order you know just to get
to get back to where i i would be more
comfortable
with being in this setting because it's
a struggle you know it's a struggle for
a brother
who dropped out in the 10th grade who
are having a work system and some most
[ __ ] that stacked up against them it
ain't easy coming up from under all of
that
plus you had the prison setting on top
of that and the [ __ ] i learned in there
man it's almost impossible for a brother
to to surface from up under all that
[ __ ] but i managed to
so i know i'm something special i know
i'm somebody to be reckoned with i know
i'm not your average [ __ ] joe
thank god because i see it for what it
is and me
i don't care how nobody else see me or
what what they take is on me it don't
matter
it's what i think and care about myself
that matters today
and i love me and i'll do everything in
my powers and make sure that i keep on
putting
forth one foot in front of the other
i'm tired i'm sick and tired of being
sick and tired
so now it's all about action ready and
not prepared or not
i'm going for what i know and that's
broke thank you